bueno la reacción más importante ha sido
la del presidente alberto fernández que
poco tiempo después de conocerse el
resultado que emitió un tuit felicitando
de manuel macarrones felicitando a los
franceses él dijo que se trató de un
triunfo del proyecto democrático de
macrón frente a las voces estridentes de
la extrema derecha y les quiero
mencionar que este no es el primer tuit
que envía alberto fernández o hilo de
tuit sino que el sábado el día antes de
las elecciones ya había enviado un hilo
de tweets respaldando al presidente
francés en su búsqueda de la reelección
y una de las cosas que mencionan en el
hilo del domingo post triunfo electoral
de makro es que para él es un elemento
clave que él está en el poder porque es
un defensor de lo que él llama el
multilateralismo especialmente en este
contexto en el que se está re dibujando
el mapa geopolítico global
además para fernández macrón es un
aliado importante el tuvo muchas
conversaciones con el presidente francés
que había dado su compromiso y había
ofrecido su asistencia en la medida de
lo posible en las negociaciones que
llevaba adelante argentina con el fondo
monetario internacional y las
negociaciones que lleva adelante el club
de parís así que hay un vínculo muy
fuerte entre los dos mandatarios además
de los vínculos entre los países donde
hay un contacto muy fuerte vinculado en
el tema de los derechos humanos de la
defensa de las cuestiones de género
también y la defensa de los derechos de
las personas lgtb y más o sea que ahí
hay un vínculo fuerte no solo a nivel
país sino especialmente entre el
mandatario argentino y el mandatario
francés ahora reelecto